céline dion au stade de france devant
plus de 80000 spectateurs unis dans une
même ferveur hier soir la star
québécoise a donné toute sa mesure pour
le premier de ces cancers qui
l'emmèneront à travers toute l'europe
même si céline dion a considérablement
allégé son programme françoise roy
blaise grumier après les rolling stones
et johnny hallyday céline dion est la
troisième artiste investir le stade de
france
c'est certain
côté
ma
à 31 ans la québécoise a tous conquis
elle est devenue l'une des plus grandes
stars du monde devant 80000 personnes
elle a chanté dansé et enthousiasmé un
public
il est vrai conquis d'avancé ce qui a
une super belle voix et il est très
lourd si maintenant ils collectibles est
amoureux de céline dion
elle a aussi beaucoup émue lorsqu'elle a
évoqué rené son mari malade qui se
repose là bas en floride
venait tempérer d'un ce moment il était
si bien conforter dans son sofa en
fleuret dans son salon et grâce à la
technologie dès ce soir venez il est
avec nous ils voient le spectacle vous
voir la fin alors mon amour cern
on est tellement beau
non
son tour
sa carrière est exemplaire sa voix
exceptionnelle elle a vendu 60 millions
d'albums en 30 mois un disque se vend
toutes les secondes et votive
elle ne connaît rien d'autre que la
chanson nous sont toujours prononcés les
mots amour et love
ce sont ses derniers concerts avant de
quitter la scène pour un long congé
sabbatique et se consacrer à sa vie
privée
en ce moment